John Paul Sartre
says, "everything
has been figured out,
except how to live."
So perhaps the better
question is not
what are we to do
with death, but what
are we to do with life?
Life exists in individual
moments, and it is up to us
to make sure that
those moments are
vast, interconnected and grand.
To make a masterpiece
out of life.
One that we would willingly
live again and again
for all of eternity.
This is what we
could strive for.
And I love this idea.
This idea of
aestheticing our lives,
of italicizing our
experience, of turning
our story into THE story.
Of seeing the universal
in the specific.
Sort of aligning ourselves with
the archetype of the hero's
journey.
Of trying to see a
departure from the ordinary
in every single instance.
A chance to learn something new.
A chance to leverage
obstacles and learn from them,
and meet people along the way
that can teach us something.
It's what the movie
Eat, Pray, Love
talks about-- quest physics.
The physics of the quest.
If you believe, and
you're willing to step out
of your comfort
zone, life will begin
at the edge of
your comfort zone.
If you're able to treat what
seems like despair, what
seems like hardship
as an opportunity
to reinvent yourself and to
transcend your own limitations,
as David Johnson says, "the
world is full of clues,
and you can read
your way though it."
If you're able to turn your
life into an art piece,
if you're able to turn your
narrative into THE narrative,
then you become that hero.
You become the god
of your own life.
It's the archetype
in every film.
It is the Joseph Campbell hero's
journey, and that's just rad.
That's just a cool idea.